foreign
most of you are already familiar with
Alexa Siri and Google Assistant
some of you are used to Smart devices
like an air conditioning system that can
sense your absence in the room and
automatically turn it off have you ever
wondered who these are or how do they do
all this and how can they be so human
don't worry this video will help you
learn everything you need to know about
these artificially intelligent devices
also known as AI agent agent is a
freestanding program or entity that
interacts with its surroundings by
sensing them with sensors acting with
actuators or effectors and so on coming
to software agents this agent acts on
sensory inputs such as
file contains keystrokes and network
packets I repeat and network packets it
has received by acting on those inputs
and showing the results on a screen
coming to human agent
we are all agents of goods humans
contain sensors like their eyes hearing
and other organs as well as actuators
like their hands legs mouths and other
bodily parts
and third one is robotic agents robotic
agent feature a variety of high quality
Motors that serve as actuators as well
as cameras and infrared range finders
that serve as sensors this is all about
examples of AI agents agents must either
to certain rules let us list them out
rule number one an AI agent needs to
have an environmental perception
rule number two decisions must be based
on observations of the environment
rule number three action should follow
decisions
and coming to rule number four the AI
agent's action have to be logical the
best possible outcome comes from making
rational decisions that maximize
performance now that we all know the
rules to follow we will understand types
of Agents
first is learning agents a learning
agent learns from its past experience it
is used in the gaming industry as this
industry needs the most reliable and
tested agent
next is reflex agent this agent focus on
the now and forget the past they
answered by applying the evident
condition action principle when a user
starts an event the agent refers to a
set of pre-programmed criteria and rules
leading to pre-programmed result you
might have heard about Tic-tac-toe and
the decision regarding that based on
reflexive agent
foreign
these agents select their behaviors in a
similar manner as reflex agent but they
have a more thorough understanding of
their surroundings the internal system
has an environmental model that
integrates with the agents past
next is goal based agent these agents
expand on the data that a model based
agent maintains by adding gold
information or data described in desired
outcomes and circumstances
next is utility based agent they are
similar to goal based agents but they
also provide an additional utility
Matrix this evaluation grants each
potential consequence in relation to the
desired outcome and chooses the curse of
action that optimizes the result
examples of rating criteria includes
factors like success probability or the
quantity of resources needed now we know
the types of Agents it's time to know
its function so let us learn about
structure of an agent many agents uses
the peas model in the structure peace is
an acronym for performance measure
environment actuators and sensors for
instance let us take vacuum cleaner as
an example
performance cleanliness and efficiency
can be considered as performance
environment drug hardwood floor living
room these can be considered as
environment for vacuum cleaner
actuator brushes wheel and vacuum bag in
a vacuum cleaner can be considered as
actuators
sensors dot detect sensor bump sensor
next we will see how to improve the
performance we only need to question
ourselves how do we increase our
performance in a task when confronting
the problem of how to improve
intelligent agent performances clearly
the solution is straightforward we carry
out the task recall the outcomes and
make adjustments in light of our
memories of Brian Price the same manner
that humans improve so do AI agents by
Saving its previous responses and
attempts the agent improves and learns
how to react more effectively in the
future artificial intelligence and
machine learning converts you I hope you
enjoyed watching this video stay tuned
for more interesting videos on the
latest Technologies till then keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here